sumándose a una creciente lista de
atentados en afganistán el grupo
yihadista estado islámico detonó dos
bombas con las que estremeció este
martes a un hospital militar de kabul
una bomba explotó en la entrada de un
hospital de 400 camas en el distrito 10
de kabul las fuerzas especiales del
emirato islámico llegaron a la zona la
explosión causó víctimas cuyos detalles
se darán a conocer más tarde las
explosiones se produjeron en la entrada
del principal centro médico militar de
kabul seguidas inmediatamente por el
asalto de un grupo de hombres armados un
portavoz talibán aseguró que cuatro de
los atacantes fueron abatidos por las
fuerzas de seguridad talibanes y que un
quinto fue capturado
sobre un incidente terrible llegaron
muchas personas heridas a este hospital
y algunos cadáveres entre las víctimas
este ataque sigue una serie de atentados
en las últimas semanas del grupo
terrorista que se ha convertido en la
mayor amenaza para el control talibán en
afganistán
work este no es el primer ataque de este
tipo estos ataques nos llevan a cabo los
que están en contra del islam no se
trata de kabul y ataques también en
provincias atacan mezquitas escuelas y
hoy atacaron el hospital donde los
pobres reciben tratamiento a
este centro médico ya sufrió en 2017
otro ataque reivindicado por el grupo
yihadista estado islámico que causó más
de una treintena de muertos y decenas de
heridos